famous player 13 points these are hard
questions
Tracy McGrady yeah either of them two
yeah Tracy McGrady
there goes one for me yeah
oh three
I don't know I didn't even know that
you ain't know that I was too quick all
right come on
what did he say I didn't hear it oh Kobe
um
Wizards Wizards I said it before you the
Washington Wizards there you go that's
cause I'm from Maryland I had season
tickets
oh no
um don't don't look at it don't look
don't say nothing hey oh Spurs didn't
they sweep his ass
ew oh Spurs first you're gonna be the
basketball player hey we got more
questions
Paul Pierce okay that was good I was
about to say Raja
uh was it Boston
no no Legos yeah
all right they got the three people oh
my God
2004 bro
[Music]
um
Lakers oh who they have on the Lakers
then oh my God that was two thousand
yeah I'm saying I wasn't alive
oh you're wrong I'm not wrong
I watch basketball
[Music]